and as for the mets tonight they're glad
to have jacob degrom back on the mound
tonight degrom with his 0.31 era get
your popcorn ready
have that cell phone on do not disturb
it's jacob de grom time as [ __ ]
hernandez digs in 1-2 coming to
hernandez and a strikeout to strap
tonight and 101 miles an hour
nick pavetta gets the call this one for
the red sox comes in at his fifth start
of the year will be tonight two-and-oh
they three four eight era the is on the
corners now for jd davis two and one to
the right hand batter
nevada deals
swinging a soft line drive caught by
bogarts
we think he caught it in the air he did
put out a force anyway and that retires
the side so pavetta escapes the two
walks
rafael devers at the plate
big open stance for devers on the left
side bogarts at second and nobody out
and divers hits it hard mcneal with a
great stop
and gets the out wow
an absolute seed off the bat of devers
and mcneal was up to the task
vasquez becomes the key hitter just two
of his last 21 82 47 with two homers
02
and a high fly ball right center field
heads into the alley that'll bring in
the run it's all the way up against the
fence bogart send the score
vasquez with a double and the red sox
take a one to nothing lead on the grom
of the mets
and there's two outs as bobby dalbeck
will hit
with the earned run to groms allowed in
this sitting his era has spiked
to 0.59 oh boy
one-two pitch
swing and a missed strike three it was a
slider
as dulbeck couldn't catch up to it jacob
degrom a little bit of a shaked head as
he comes off the mound doesn't seem like
he was too happy with that inning as
boston scored a run two hits and they
leave a man at third we'll go to the
bottom of the second it's one nothing
boston dominic smith over his last eight
is hitting 217 with two homers
red sacks have the best record of any
team in baseball since inner league play
started in 1998
264 wins
184 losses playing 595 baseball
that's
second best in the national league 217
and 206.
strike called over the inside corner he
spotted that fastball beautifully at the
knees third inning about to begin at
citi field jacob degrom has struck out
two
in the first two innings
needs to get to 10 for the night to
get past nolan ryan for the most
strikeouts through five starts to begin
a season
if he gets to 14 it would be the fourth
time in a row
which would be the first time in major
league history at any pitcher at 14
strikeouts in four straight starts maybe
he'll get one here against the pitcher
nick pavetta to begin the third here we
go again 2-2
fastball swung on and missed slider
actually down and away and pavetta goes
down on strike's third strikeout for
degrom
[ __ ] hernandez struck out to begin the
ball game red sex leading at one to
nothing
that's looped into left on comes dom
smith and he slides and makes
the matador catch for the second half
two down bases empty here's francisco
lindor
1-0 pitch that's fouled by lindor off of
the catcher's mask
and actually got jerry lane and vasquez
was trying to grab jerry lane to keep
him from falling and now there is
a lot of attention being paid here to
jerry lane the home plate umpire
who is very woozy it seems and
a bit slumped over as he's being held up
by vasquez and lendore and now brian
chiclo the mets head athletic trainer
and the rest of the umpiring crew has
come to home plate to check on jerry
lane
the second base umpire dan merzelle
will probably go down and put on the
equipment
the 2-2 swing and a miss he struck him
out elevated fastball put him down four
strikeouts for pavetta he overcomes the
delay
jd martinez leads off in the fourth
inning and de graham ready deals 0-2
swing and a miss got him with a slider
and martinez down on strikes fourth
strike out of the night
for jacob degrom well christian vasquez
will now step in he has produced the red
sox run with a double that drove in
bogarts in the second inning hunter
wendell said taking over behind the
plate after jerry lane was knocked out
of the game
now the 1-2
swing and a miss
got him with a slider down and away
strikeout number five for degrom he gets
a couple in the fourth inning no runs a
hit and one left on we have played three
and a half at citi field red sox one
mets nothing first time up for gonzalez
he saw a steady diet and change ups the
groms one-two pitch swinging a miss
strike three letter high fastball
nothing but heat to marwyn gonzalez
sixth strikeout for de grom here's bobby
dalbeck he struck out his first time up
one two swing and a miss strike three
that time the slider fools dalbeck
back-to-back strikeouts here in the
fifth three in a row overall and seven
on the night here's the pitcher nick
pavetta the 2-2
swinging a miss strike three degrom
strikes out the side in the fifth he
punches out nick pavetta to win the
inning and now jacob degrom has eight
strikeouts in his five innings tonight
top of the order and nimbo was walked
and tapped to third
two ball two strike pitch here it comes
curve foul tipped into the mid strike
three swinging he got him
so that is
the seventh strikeout we'll see if he
comes back for more batter is jd
martinez
for dugo at first and one out
and martinez
swings and misses on the fastball and
that is strikeout number nine for degrom
and that ties him with nolan ryan 59
strikeouts through five starts he has
had every reason over the last few years
to throw teammates under the bus and has
not done it once
not when they haven't hit for him not
when they haven't relieved for him not
when they haven't played defense for him
as francisco lindor faces the new red
sox pitcher
right-hander garrett whitlock a rookie
the one-two swing and a miss he struck
him out went up the ladder with a
fastball sia
door hearing it from the fans again
two on two out for dominic smith
whitlock stands tall
sets in the 01.
change up cued in front of the plate
it's a fair ball vasquez picks it up
with a bare hand throws to first in time
inning over
jam escape well nice moment here at city
field as the scoreboard pays tribute to
jerry blevins who announced his
retirement yesterday he's here at the
ballpark with his wife and kids
and getting a very nice ovation from the
city field crowd oh look at the kids so
excited
like what's happening but we love it
mr and mrs meddar excited
now francisco lindor has walked and
struck out twice tonight
he's going to rip down all the catch is
going to be made by gonzalez
who stole the heads
that was an absolute laser boy he timed
that perfectly
here's their last hope dominic smith two
down bases empty bottom of the ninth
3-2 to dominic smith
swag and a miss and the red sox win
another one one nothing tonight